in Hawaii Native students are dropping
out at an alarming rate only four out of
five finish high school and only two of
those will earn a college degree and in
Waianae Hawaii the problem is even worse
this Coast has the highest concentration
of indigenous Hawaiians it is also one
of the poorest regions in the state only
14% of the people here hold a college
degree but one farm is working to solve
this education crisis by combining
modern agriculture and ancestral
Hawaiian practices now farms in Waianae
Hawaii pays for native youth to go to
college and teaches them how to run it
based on indigenous principles
[Music]
Puri sana also known as Cowie
manages my all organic farms ten years
ago she participated in their internship
program today she's leading it every
morning before we start the day here at
mato we come together in a big circle
and we do all Olli
[Music]
mm-my is a chant that we do to ground
ourselves to start the day Conal or
imbalance the work that we do is secret
[Music]
I'm sorry about 5:15 ish right now at
the farm we're harvesting Crowley kill
for our order today maybe close to 200
pounds of this today which is actually
kind of a small order for us most of
this kill will be going to restaurants
here on Oahu when I graduated high
school early
oh it's quiet little thing just I
couldn't even look have eye contact with
like anybody at the farm as I got
connected more at the farm and I got to
taste food I got to see food girl I got
to feed my family I got to feed others
in the community I really started to
feel like I was a part of something
beyond me in Waianae college tuition
remains unaffordable for many but at my
old farms young people can work the land
in exchange for college scholarships and
a monthly stipend this is our sassy
salad mix salad with a kick salad with
some spice
Sally Woodson attitude Charisse has
lived in Waianae her whole life growing
up I always felt really lucky because I
always got to go to the beach every day
I got to see these beautiful mountains
as I got older I started to hear all
these stereotypes about my community and
that kind of just said well that it was
directly about me when I got accepted
into like eh Manoa I didn't have the
money for it I didn't want to get into
debt and I didn't want to ask my parents
for money because I'm the oldest of
seven and one of my teachers recommended
me to do this program I found a family
that I never knew I needed now paid her
tuition and allowed her to get a degree
in Hawaiian studies when I first came to
the farm I never thought I would ever be
a farmer I just wanted to use this as a
platform for me to to get my degree and
which I did and I ended up falling in
love with farming and working with land
and with food and the same thing with
some of these guys
[Music]
when I heard about mato and this
individual connected more to what I
wanted to do as a person 5 a.m. it's
kind of rough for me but then I just
think of when you can actually hear
nature and then you see the Sun Rise and
everything is a good start for my day
actually they're probably not gonna be
farmers but you know if these guys end
up becoming doctors or social workers or
teachers in our community I think it's
super critical for them now that they're
in the program they can bring these
values to their workspace and to their
families my passion is working on the
land it's very challenging to balance
school and work but the best way to the
better yourself is to get out that
comfort zone
I think it's a perfect opportunity for
me to do that one of our biggest
philosophy here is like to harvest the
same day that it's delivered so
everything you see here is harvested
this morning young people in Waianae
face high levels of drug addiction
domestic violence and a lack of access
to healthy food but not here on the farm
Hokulani keppo o Florence plans to
continue farming here for at least her
four years of college I became a mom at
20 years old
they're like always telling me how cool
you're doing awesome it's just those
words sleep I kind of go back home to my
son feeling good
when they thought went really good with
the outside crew we're gonna try doing
more planting today so just be ready no
kind of organic Cherise and her
colleagues at mow farms believe that
reconnecting with the life ways of their
ancestors is essential to the
development of young leaders 85% of
their student cohort is indigenous
Hawaiian in ancient Hawaiian times land
stewardship meant to take care of the
land from the mountain to the ocean you
only take what you need and when you
take care of the land the land takes
care of you it's wholly starts to change
the dynamic of how we kind of clear food
and with each other there are a whole
bunch of other people doing good jobs
Burlington Caminos joined the farm over
10 years ago
he leads the social enterprise of Mao
farms integrating the twin pillars of
modern economics with traditional
relationship with the land I'm actually
really interested in the idea of
indigenized and digitizing is to me
means I you look at the structures they
were thrust upon you where this economic
social whatnot and how do we purpose
these structures to be vehicles for
ancestral responsibilities so it means
that you have to have dual fluencies you
have to have a fluency in your ancestry
and a fluency contemporary spaces we're
not just providing empowerment like we
have bottom lines we have to enter a
daily basis to take that kind of risk
with them was a huge gamble
one of the first interns we took it with
was collie at 27 Colliers in all dirty
mouth farms has grown into the largest
organic farm on the island of Oahu and
over 300 students have participated in
their internship program every Saturday
morning Cherise and her students travel
to Honolulu to sell their vegetables at
a local farmers market and engage with a
larger community so you can just measure
Mollick by your hand like
big bunch because we only saw these for
$1 anyway so lies for $1 early on to the
knowledge is and the practices that
people are calling new and sustainable
it's not new yo its new with a silent K
like we've known this our ancestors
known this I just want to continue do
more for you know the people of what and
I and evidently the world because we are
all connected
[Music]